artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence AI image generators even
the least talented of us can create
artwork with just a few clicks over the
last few months we've seen an incredible
surge in AI content generated using AI
programs as tools like dollies stable
diffusion and mid-journey have become
accessible to the general public and as
a result legitimate concerns have been
raised about whether or not these
programs are by their very nature
committing copyright infringement in
these data sets there exists billions of
copyrighted images it's just like
dumping all of recorded human history
into a black box and now there's finally
been a lawsuit filed in the Federal
District Court of Northern California it
attaches a few defendants but most
notably stability AI the creator of
stable diffusion and mid-journey which
also uses stable diffusion the suit
claims that stable diffusion is
committing copyright infringement on a
mind-bogglingly massive scale I'm Jake
Watson a licensed and Bard attorney in
the state of California who spent the
last 12 years making cutting-edge
digital art with Corridor in this video
I'll explain to you what this case is
all about and why that's not even the
real issue divulging instead the legal
secrets of what's truly at stake
[Music]
now the suit claims that the nearly 6
billion training images which have been
scraped from web pages and other sources
across the internet were obtained
without the consent of the image owners
or the website operators the data set is
so large that to download it takes
almost 240 terabytes of open disk space
on a computer that's a huge data set it
is in large part the lion 5B data set
that makes stable diffusion renowned for
how good it is at generating AI images
the class action lawsuit asserts that
this is a violation of the exclusive
rights of the copyright holders in those
images
and they're right stability doesn't deny
that huge swaths of the training images
are copyrighted which in the most basic
terms is copyright infringement on a
mind-bogglingly massive scale if you're
one of those people that argue it's okay
because stability is open source and
it's not really making that much money
because it's free to download well I've
got news for you uh whether or not
something is committing copyright
infringement has absolutely no bearing
on whether it is free and open source so
just take that argument and drop it in
the toilet because it doesn't matter
okay fine but how is it that the class
action lawsuit that was just filed isn't
really about this well it's not really
about whether they committed copyright
infringement because they did but copies
of the training images aren't actually
in the distributed model say what the
real trick of stable diffusion and what
the plaintiffs more wisely argue is that
it created latent images of all the 5.85
billion images the model was trained on
these latent images are developed
through a process of machine learning
where a training image is associated
with a specific word and then gradually
more and more noise is introduced over
the training image until eventually the
entire original training image is
completely obscured by the noise a
second process of machine learning then
occurs reversing this process only this
time the noises gradually reduced and
the program attempts to construct its
own image that is visually a
reconstruction of the original image it
was just trained on but it never quite
Nails this to an exact copy the
plaintiff suggest however that the
latent images are copies of the training
images all the same well they stop short
of actually calling them exact copies or
reproductions they do refer to them as
reconstructed copies and infer the
argument that they are for all intents
and purposes copies
their strongest argument however and the
thing that leads to the core issue that
this case is all about which we still
haven't gotten to is that any image
generated from stable diffusion is a
derivative work of the training image
the model was built on a derivative work
is a work based on or derived from one
or more already existing Works
translations movie adaptations art
reproductions and new editions of books
now the suit claims that once the
program is trained it's data mesh the
statistical mesh of data that contains
all of its billions of latent images can
be manipulated through conditioning and
interpolation to describe this the
complaint uses the example of a dog
wearing a hat eating an ice cream cone
in this example the text prompts of a
dog wearing a hat eating an ice cream
cone are conditioning data that inform
the model what latent images to call
upon then through a process of
interpolation the program will combine
the latent images together into
something that's legible to the human
eye the argument is that this
interpolation is still entirely and
completely Reliant upon the latent
images which are solely and exclusively
derived from the training images which
are copyrighted so regardless of the
fact that the resulting image of a dog
wearing a hat eating an ice cream cone
looks nothing like any of the original
training images there's a very good
argument that the plaintiffs make that
every image the model generates is a
derivative work and this matters because
the right to produce and distribute
derivative works is known as the
adaptation right and it is one of the
exclusive rights of copyright meaning
that a derivative work cannot be created
without the authorization from the
copyright owner however a work is found
to be transformative rather than
derivative if it Alters an original work
with new expression meaning or message
or when it adds value to the original
work by creating new information new
Aesthetics new insights or new
understandings a transform formative
work takes the original copyright work
and changes its very nature to such a
degree that the use no longer qualifies
as infringing because it serves an
entirely new purpose it is not merely
derivative the significance of this
Nuance difference between derivative and
transformative cannot be overstated
works that are derivative require
permission from the copyright owner but
works that are transformative do not
from this perspective we can view the
real issue of the case with Precision
the real issue is whether it's
stability's use of the 5.85 billion
training images that make up the Lyon 5B
data set constitutes fair use
now before we dig into this any further
there's something that I have to admit
2023 is a brand new year and courtesy of
today's sponsor Squarespace you now have
the tools to make it better than ever
that's right I'm doing an integration
right in the middle of this Squarespace
has beautiful award-winning templates
and 24 7 customer service now what else
do you need to know well a couple things
in fact look over the last few years the
hot trend has been doing subscription
services for everything under the sun
well with Squarespace they've integrated
that membership ability into your
website that means that you can create a
members only area on your website which
allows you to put things behind paywalls
offer exclusive Services things like
that all with the click and the breeze
of a few Easy Button they also allow you
social media formatting which allows you
to make one post from your Squarespace
website and have that automatically go
out and be formatted to a multitude of
different social media platforms save
yourself a lot of time and that's a
great thing Squarespace also has some of
the best in game analytics out of any
other website builder out there this
allows you to better understand what
people are doing when they come to your
website and how to better improve your
website over time to give people an even
better experience I mean that sounds
like an A plus in law school to me so if
you're interested in getting started
building your own website today head on
over to squarespace.com Corridor crew to
get 10 of your first purchase of a
website or domain that's squarespace.com
corridorcrew for 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain or just
click the link in the description
anyways let's get back to this class
action lawsuit
[Music]
the results of a decision in favor of
fair use would have far-reaching
consequences effectively allowing AI
image generators carte blanche to create
models trained on works of any kind no
matter how large and without the
permission consent or authorization of
any of the copyright owners all of whom
have contributed valuable works of
originality to image generator models
which owe their principal value in how
good they work to those underlying
images now you might think Hey Jake this
isn't that big of a deal okay all they
did was take some images and allow more
images to be generated from this I don't
see what the big issue is well look if
you don't think that this technology is
going to continue to improve and improve
think again this technology is going to
affect all audio visual entertainment as
we know it forever into our future
that's where we're at right now so we
need to figure this out we cannot
understate that now back to fair use
okay fair use is an affirmative defense
meaning that it can't be brought by a
plaintiff to initiate a lawsuit it can
only be argued by a defendant once a
plaintiff asserts a copyright violation
and at the moment we're still waiting on
stability's answer to the initial
complaint that said it's hard to
conceive how they wouldn't make a fair
use argument here so here's how that
analysis might go by a court to
determine whether or not their use of
the lion 5B data set constitutes a
transformative fair use at its core fair
use is intended to prevent a rigid
application of copyright law that would
otherwise stifle the very creativity
copyright law is designed to Foster to
make a finding of fair use courts
consider four factors now this is the
most critical part of how this whole
thing will shake out so don't fall
asleep here a failure to understand the
Nuance will ultimately lead to a failure
to understand the conclusion itself
first the courts consider whether the
purpose and character of the new use is
transformative of the original remember
a transformative use must take the
original copyrighted work and transform
its very nature to such a significant
degree that they use no longer qualifies
as infringing because it serves a new
purpose that said just because a new use
is found to be transformative does not
guarantee that the new use is fair
that's because the courts will also
consider the nature of the original work
the amount and substantiality of the
original work used in the new work and
finally whether or not the new use
undermines the value of and market for
the original the commercial value of the
new use can't be one that undermines or
replaces the value of the original work
instead fair use requires something
highly new something original a new
purpose at which the new use is being
directed and lastly courts always
consider the prior precedent in making a
determination of fair use well nothing
quite like AI image generators has
existed before and there are a multitude
of cases worth considering I find two
input particular that stand out first
Perfect 10 versus Google this case was
brought against Google by adult magazine
publisher Perfect 10 where Google
provided thumbnail copies of Perfect 10
images through its search function
Perfect 10 then sued Google for
copyright infringement but the court
found that Google's use of the
thumbnails was fair use primarily due to
the highly transformative nature of the
use ruling that Google transformed the
images from one of entertainment to one
of retrieving information and noting
that search engine technology provides
an astoundingly valuable public benefit
which should not be jeopardized just
because it might affect someone's sales
that's pretty strong precedent the
second case is authors Guild versus
Google which was brought by different
groups of Publishers against Google over
whether Google had committed copyright
infringement when it scanned and
digitized copies of printed books into
an online searchable database the court
affirmed defining of fair use stating
that digitizing the books creating a
search functionality for them and
displaying only Snippets of them in the
search results was fair use it also
found the purpose of the copywriting was
highly transformative and did not
undermine the market for The Originals
despite the fact that Google had a
commercial nature and a profit
motivation in the new use
think about that didn't matter the fact
that Google had a commercial nature and
a profit motivation in the new use
didn't matter that Google was using
thumbnails and that those thumbnails had
an astoundingly valuable public benefit
so what does this mean for AI art well
as you can see courts rely heavily upon
the transformative nature of a new use
and I think the case against stability
if it doesn't settle first will be no
different here I think overall stability
does have a very good argument for fair
use because it appears that their use of
the training images in the lion 5B data
set is highly transformative such that
it creates a new purpose for the
original images I don't think there's
much denying that in addition it doesn't
appear that this new use by stability
deprives the copyright owners of their
right to control and benefit from their
original work however given that this
type of technology has never existed
before especially given how quickly it's
developed I think that as with the dawn
of the internet we need to be very
careful in considering the far-reaching
implications that a finding of fair use
might have now I do think there is a
world where people are less inclined to
desire the art of the artists who have
work in AI image generating data sets I
think that that is a possibility that
can exist I don't think we're in that
space right now but I do think that is a
reality and there needs to be an
absolute recognition of value that but
for the sheer mass of data and the
quality of images included in that data
stable diffusion would not be nearly as
good as it is the old saying in data
science that crap in equals crap out is
100 True here now whether or not that
unfairly deprives the copyright owner of
their right to control and benefit from
their work I do think remains to be seen
right now it doesn't appear to be going
in that direction but we're very early
in all of this I mean stable diffusion
wasn't even released publicly until
August of 2022
and this nascent stage of development
may have an effect on a Court's finding
of fair use because once it's given it's
hard to take back in addition I pray
that the lawyers on both sides of this
are good enough to explain to the courts
exactly how this technology works and
we're not dealing with another Senate
type inquiry of Mark Zuckerberg if so
how do you sustain a business model in
which users don't pay for your service
Senator we run ads
oh my God at the end of the day I am
thankful that this lawsuit is being
brought I know it sounds weird but I'm
also thankful that companies like
stability are pushing the boundaries of
what you can do with artistic tools and
I think that this fight will ultimately
lead to a better coexistence of both
arts and entertainment and computer
science well into the future and that's
good for everybody but my friends this
is just the beginning literally as I was
writing this video news broke that Getty
Images is suing stability in the United
Kingdom for also alleged copyright
violations there doesn't appear to be
any shortage of litigation coming but
perhaps just maybe if we can separate
our emotions from it we might be able to
see that this legal fight is exactly
what needs to be happening right now
what a wild time to be alive if you
liked this video let us know in the
comments because I would love to do more
it was a ton of fun to write and to
research and to create and as always
thanks for watching